good evening welcome to washington i'm
bret baer president biden is in houston
right now he's delivering remarks at
this hour at a coronavirus
vaccination facility run by the federal
emergency management agency as you see
him there
we are monitoring these remarks and
we'll turn around any news
first tonight white house correspondent
peter ducey on the president's domestic
trip
when many of the questions he's facing
are about foreign policy
surrounding the order for air strikes in
syria that we first told you about at
the end of special report last night
good evening peter
good evening brett within the last hour
on his way to those remarks president
biden told
reporters those air strikes were to send
a message to
iran quote you can't act with impunity
be careful
and the day after hurting iranian-backed
forces he is down there trying to
heal texas you're saving people's lives
and they're
doing if my mother would save sure
you're doing god's work
on the way to texas the white house
explained the rationale behind the first
air strikes biden ordered as
commander-in-chief
destroying facilities used by
iranian-backed groups who targeted
american interests in iraq the president
is sending an unambiguous message
that he's going to act to protect
americans
and when threats are posed he has the
right to take an action at the time
and in the manner of his choosing and
every peaceful response must have been
exhausted already according to foreign
policy rules biden himself explained at
the pentagon two weeks ago
the central indispensable mission of the
department of defense is to deter
aggression from our enemies
and if required to fight and win wars to
keep america safe
but i believe force should be a tool of
last resort
not first but some democrats wish biden
would have asked them for an okay
senator tim kaine protests offensive
military action
without congressional approval is not
constitutional absent extraordinary
circumstances
congress must be fully briefed on this
matter expeditiously
when locations in syria were targeted in
2017 by trump
gensake had questions quote also what is
the legal authority for strikes assad is
a brutal dictator but syria
is a sovereign country now she argues
that was different because
trump was interfering in a syrian matter
2017 was an attack on the syrian on
syrian military installations in
response to a chemical weapons attack
last night was a strike on militant
groups in defense of u.s
personnel under attack in iraq there's a
massive difference in both policy
and law there's also a massive
difference between house and senate
rules
the house is allowed to pass a coven 19
relief bill with a 15
minimum wage attached the senate is not
according to the senate parliamentarian
progressives are now pushing vice
president harris
to overrule there are progressives who
believe that the vice president should
do the same thing that
vice president rockefeller did vice
president humphrey did
in not accepting the advice of the
parliamentarian
not happening according to the white
house well the president the vice
president
respect the senate process and will not
overrule the parliamentarians decision
in this case
in a statement last night shinsaki said
president biden is disappointed in this
outcome
but he couldn't have been surprised
because this aired
three weeks ago but that may not be in
your american rescue
no i put it in but i don't think it's
going to survive
he was right but as of right now even
without the minimum wage
increase in there this package has zero
republican
support so even though jensaki told me
yesterday that the white house was not
resigned
to trying to pass this with democratic
votes only
it looks like that's what's happening
right
peter ducey live on the north lawn peter
thank you syria is condemning thursday's
military action calling it a cowardly
attack and urging president biden
not to follow what he calls the law of
the jungle
correspondent trey yanks has the latest
from our middle east newsroom
fox news has learned the threat level
for american service members in iraq
was raised today as the u.s military
fears retaliation
for airstrikes overnight in eastern
syria
according to u.s officials seven
500-pound laser guided bombs
were dropped near the iraqi border
killing a reported 22 iranian-backed
fighters
u.s and coalition personnel in iraq were
targeted three separate times
with rockets this month by
iranian-backed shia militias
one attack happened 11 days ago in the
city of verbeel
killing a contractor and injuring five
americans
including one u.s service member we're
confident
in the target that we went after we know
what we hit
and we're confident that that target was
being used
by the same shia militia that
that conducted the strikes the pentagon
quickly released a statement calling the
strikes proportionate
and done in consultation with coalition
partners
it was the first major american military
action abroad
since president biden took office and
the department of defense was clear
these targets were meant to send a
message the ongoing provocations
from iranian proxies come amid a
backdrop of significant tension
regarding the 2015 nuclear deal the
stalemate has only increased regional
provocations
against the u.s and its close ally
israel
a high-ranking israeli official told fox
news on friday
that the jewish state was notified ahead
of the u.s airstrikes in syria
reports last month indicate israel is
preparing plans to strike iranian
nuclear sites
if needed the united states iran and
israel are all making ongoing
calculations we do know the region
is waiting to see what happens next but
a single misstep
could lead to a much larger conflict in
the middle east
brett hey trey there in israel how much
concern is there that the by the
administration despite this action
against iranian militias
is really working hard to re-establish
this iran nuclear deal
the major concern for israel brett
according to officials we've spoken with
here in jerusalem
is that the biden administration is
going to cut a deal of their own
with the other partners to the jcpoa
agreement
that would ultimately leave the proxy
threats off the table
israel faces threats from places like
gaza with groups like hamas and islamic
jihad
and also lebanon with groups like
hezbollah brett
trey yingst live in our middle east
newsroom trey thank you